so mike remember our friend e frog when
you left from that voicemail
yeah okay no
hey thanks for tuning in folks don't
listen to you no
he really is oh this is great and he
didn't just here's the thing mike cause
i
i keep forgetting how much bigger our
show is than it used to be
a lot of people call them oh no a lot of
people
[Laughter]
we do forget sometimes a lot of people
we don't have like 20 people listening
a lot of people call them hey thanks for
tuning in folks
to listen to your saved messages
to change your personal options press 4
for more information about your mailbox
press zero
well i don't know what i want main menu
yeah to listen to your saved messages
listen to this folks message
all right
advisory council uh some of our
associates
i've been receiving some disturbing
phone calls from you and i've been
called in
uh to inform you that uh you need to
back
off this chemtrail stuff
do you understand
he
i was like yeah maybe he will maybe he
won't but wow
holy well we know he got it we know he
got it
to go to the next message press pound
listen kid if you don't lay off the
chemtrail stuff
there's gonna be a funk with your name
on it
in a fema camp oh really
kid leave the chemtrail
stuff alone a bunch of females
oh i will okay this guy's gonna believe
every word of this
press one two transfers
messages
we know what your phone looks like
all right i'm just going to hang up on
that so
oh and he's getting a lot of text
messages oh no why not
maybe you shouldn't give your phone
number out on [ __ ] youtube
[ __ ] i didn't mention the chemtrails
oh darn it i just did oh no
what's gonna happen to me oh i guess i'm
going to end up in a bunk
what do you think i can't cough guy
he might like he he
actually he but he believes he believes
it
he believes what he's he believed the
most they tell you that america sucks
and that you should hate uh everything
in americana
and uh you should love china and suck
china
china's uh big fat hairy toe what if i
buy
old vintage turn of the century
american-made china
uh wouldn't that be americana
all right deep state mike confirmed only
[ __ ] his brain up
yeah that's what they want
well i guess yeah i was kidding man i'm
gonna end up in a fema camp
i don't think i will though it's gonna
happen
i'm not going to be taken alive that's
all that's going to happen
that's all i can say about that okay
that statement will be slow
down that statement alone is the kind of
thing that gets sheriffs to come talk to
you
yeah like you can't say [ __ ] like that
no the price is right
you got one hardcore red-blooded
american ready to fight
right here fight lawful and legally why
is he turning did he turn into
a dusty road impression yeah because i'm
ready to fight right
alaskan dusty roads so get ready for it
baby
because i'm gonna have all kinds of guns
in my 60 old
stroke victim wife daddy justice comes
along
and then you got to just pick up the gun
off the street that was
dropped by your fellow companion soldier
is this
and carry on you my friend have been
playing way too much like apex legends
or pubg
fallout they asked me if i was a hero
and i said no
but i served in the company of them but
it's like you know
it's like worthless man when you kill
like super mutants
because they never have good guns on
them you know it's like always pipe
pistols or
you know whatever so you gotta find the
gunners
the gunners always have the good stuff
on them
in the fight like back in
seven 1776 says how many sex son says
again
so as we speak
the spirit of humanity is rising
and i'm here to raise the alarm here's
another restaurant
i just called my phone because i posted
fu
uh epa on youtube
i put my number out there my personal
information
oops my bad but i was leaving a message
for the epa to call me and i guess they
did call me was that really the epa i
don't know
i don't really think so i think it was
just some liberals trying to get off
dude we got off totally got off
you did yeah yeah just now
on their little power trip because they
think they own everybody
well guess what you don't own me i'm a
red-blooded american
i'm here in alaska you want me come and
get me please do i'm
i'm ready to die for what i believe in
i'm sick of this [ __ ] footing around
let's get it on e-frog out
so e-frog's doing good
[Music]
of course welcome to the voicemail of
nine zero zero
two four this person cannot be reached
at the moment
please leave a message after the tone
after you leave a message
you can modify it by pressing pound
oh hey ethan uh this is alex calling uh
from austin
uh giving you a call of uh i was
checking out your youtube channel you
may have heard of my uh website before
infowars
uh anyway i'm calling to uh possibly
give you a job opportunity if you're
interested
uh give me a call back uh 407-630-9636 i
want you to give me a call that's my uh
second cell phone number and i'd like to
talk to you about an opportunity we've
got exclusively for you if you're
interested all right hope to hear from
you soon take care pal to re-record
press one to listen again press two
to delete press three to confirm
press pound your message has been
recorded
all right and hopefully that uh if we
can keep this little game going
oh no he is he is going you i think he's
gonna buy it
i think he's gonna think you're alex
jones because
mike does the best alex jones in the
business uh
i mean i won't you think we could talk
him into flying to austin
can we take can we take it he doesn't
have the money there's no way
he might be struggling when he makes the
money happen let me ask you something
like you know there's people back when i
had like no money and i hadn't
wasn't doing any show if alex jones
called me and offered me a gig do you
think i wouldn't have been able to
scrape up the money to get off oh no
yeah of course
yeah i think we could get idiot to go to
austin and go stay at like a la quinta
and then just go there and be like well
um
how's everybody doing out there on
youtube so it turns out
that i have been fooled and that it
wasn't alex actually calling me
i should have checked into that before i
booked a flight